here's what would happen if you lived on  kepler-22b  kepler-22b is lucky to have a star  that's remarkably similar to ours but  its close proximity to its star allows  the planet to receive about the same  amount of light as we get on earth  now scientists don't know for sure that  kepler-22b is even a rocky planet it  might be gaseous or it could be entirely  covered with water  if you and the other first settlers woke  up from your cryosleep to find  yourselves on a gas planet well that'd  be a downer you wouldn't even have a  solid surface to land your ship  in that case you and your crew would  need to figure out how to build a cloud  city orbiting the planet if you landed  on an ocean planet a submarine town  would be in order if it was a rocky  planet the surface would be scorching  hot you'd need to use robots to build  underground shelters so